buonasera a tutti io
avete parlato tanto di innovazione oggi
è lo step precedente e la ricerca
io vi parlerò della ricerca della mia
esperienza di vita di ricerca attraverso
questi tre step sognare e osare e
rendere possibile
chi è ricercatore deve per forza avere
sognato e il sogno a due atti
fondamentali un atto di coraggio e un
atto di fedeltà il ricercatore quanto
più è fedele al proprio sogno iniziale e
alla propria idea quanto più sarà saprà
forgiarla nel tempo
e quanto più a godrà di una stabilità
psichica che gli permetterà di avere le
idee di sfornare le idee perché questo è
fondamentale se poi vogliamo arrivare
all'innovazione quindi fedeltà al sogno
e fedeltà al sogno è anche una fedeltà a
quelli che sono i principi che sin da
bambini da ragazzi ci portano ad essere
affascinati dall attività di ricerca
vediamo questo il primo contributo video
e queste sono tre persone
a cui darà mi aiuto ma deve essere una
cosa molto importante
una cosa che non possono fare da sole
perciò io lo faccio per loro e loro lo
fanno per altre tre persone
siamo a 9 e aggiungo 3 da ognuno poi è
molto importante usare questo articolo
francesco alberoni che è apparso qualche
tempo fa sul corriere della sera ma è
rinvenibile in rete particolarmente
illuminante per sopravvivere la scienza
ha bisogno di irregolarità un buono
scienziato un buon ricercatore deve
avere un pensiero irregolare se si vuole
andare all'innovazione
l'innovazione non è barocca osare o dire
avere il coraggio delle proprie idee
occorre non tenere di avere un'idea
diversa da quella corrente e soprattutto
bisogna diffidare ed essere molto
critici su quelli che sono i dogmi
correnti ve lo dimostra adesso con un
esempio semplicissimo per esempio io mi
occupo di medicina tutti voi sicuramente
molti di voi avranno dosato la sideremia
quando si va dal medico e la quantità di
ferro che circola nel sangue e dogma
dice che il ferro viene trasportato da
un trasportatore specifico c'è una
proteina che lo aggancia e come un
piccolo treno in cui si siede
comodamente il ferro e il ferro va solo
su quella proteina per cui quando noi
usiamo la sideremia non facciamo altro
che dosare il ferro che attaccato il suo
trasportatore specifico vediamo un
esperimento che potete fare tutti voi
una fiala di ferro e un flaconcino pino
di proteine completamente diverse sono
quelle meno specifiche
e quelli che abbiamo maggiormente
circolanti nel nostro sangue
prendete una fiala di ferro da inserite
dentro un pezzettino agitate e vedete
che tutto quanto si lega perfettamente
in realtà tre album in sé è anche il
giorno dopo il legame è stabilissimo che
cosa succede quindi succede che il ferro
si può legare a qualunque tipo di
trasportatore ma noi non lo sappiamo
perché quando facciamo la sideremia
tutto questo non lo vediamo il ferro che
è legato ad altre albumine o ad altre
proteine si chiama non transfer in ai
bond iron che è disponibile solo nei
laboratori di ricerca e quando i
laboratori di ricerca vanno vedere si
scoprono delle cose mostruose tipo alti
livelli di ferro legato all'album in sé
come abbiamo visto in quello esperimento
è con malattie di cuore malattie delle
coronarie nelle donne dopo la menopausa
malattie neurodegenerative come
alzheimer parkinson quindi capite e
questo è uno dei miliardi di esempi
poter stare qua dei giorni a farvi
capire quanti dogmi non provati di
quanti dubbi non provati si nutre la
medicina osare e prima di tutto
conoscenza non ci si butta fuori dalla
finestra osare avere il coraggio di
affrontare problematiche difficili come
quelle che possono essere così
nell'immaginifico rappresentata in
questo bellissimo quadro che nessuno di
voi se non lo conosceste potrebbe
immaginare che è un picasso è un picasso
conservato barcellona è un'opera
giovanile
lui li aveva meno di 20 anni
della gravità delle situazioni che deve
affrontare il medico moderno non c'è
nessuna nuova conoscenza se non si osa e
soprattutto è molto importante anche che
il ricercatore abbia avuto una abitudine
ad osare è un'abitudine alla conoscenza
e in questo è fondamentale il maestro
chi ci ha preceduto nella strada prima
cosa che il mondo si aspetta da te
niente niente
mio dio ragazze ragazzi ha assolutamente
ragione
niente eppure vi guardate intorno ea voi
non piace il mondo come e se il mondo è
un'enorme delusione siamo fregati
a meno che a meno che non prendete le
cose che non vi piacciono di questo
mondo e le sbattete potete cominciare a
farlo oggi d'oro momento cos'è cos'è che
non va qual è il problema si è tipo così
così come ci sarà una parola per finire
la frase qualcuno la giustizia strano
pazzesco faticoso barboso barboso
faticoso che ne dite di possibile
è possibile il regno della possibilità
esiste dove in ognuno di voi
perciò potete farlo
potete sorprenderci spetta a voi potete
starvene imparati e lasciarlo
atrofizzare rendere possibile in realtà
è la parte più difficile di tutte
esistono tanti ricercatori con ottime
idee anche in grado di svilupparle nei
laboratori
però poi quando dobbiamo togliere la
stretta delle mani
immaginate in quella foto raffigurato in
quella foto che tengono all'interno la
nostra idea per poterla finalmente far
lavorare farla e renderla disponibile
per tutti o per l'innovazione di cui
vogliamo parlare troveremo tante
difficoltà io personalmente ne ho avute
sempre moltissime che sono detrattori
una categoria interessante sono i the
legittime tori e poi dovrete combattere
contro i conflitti di interesse che
possono essere economici ma anche non
economici ma addirittura nuovi interessi
economici che voi potreste generare
perché voi siete portatori
dell'innovazione e quindi della
ricchezza
potreste avere dei problemi a causa di
questo ma non vi voglio parlare di me
voglio fare un discorso generale e farvi
capire che persona è ben più illustri di
me specialmente nel campo della ricerca
biomedica hanno sofferto di questo un
esempio è quest'uomo che voi vedete
fleming a cui si deve l'invenzione degli
antibiotici
quando egli andò la royal society e
spiegò che una stupida muffa trovata
attorno attaccato un muro ad un secchio
di acqua piovana poteva guarire una
malattia mortale come può essere la
poteva essere la broncopolmonite generò
più ilarità che consensi
e mentre egli cercava di rendere
possibile
la sua scoperta e si arrovellava su come
poterlo fare in realtà molti speculatori
avevano già pensato di utilizzarlo per
ben altro
e una bella mattina fleming si alzò e
per le vie di londra trovò questo tipo
di tabloid in cui la penicillina sasso
scoperta non veniva usata negli ospedali
per le gravi malattie infettive ma
veniva utilizzata in ambulatori a
pagamento per poter permettere la cura
di una malattia venerea che rendeva
diciamo i rapporti sociali o o sessuali
dell'alta borghesia londinese difficili
e quando lui poté finalmente rendere
possibile la sua idea lo dovette
semplicemente al fatto che una persona
molto importante sua amica stava ansan
mary's hospital affetta da una meningite
ormai stava morendo e lui l'ha guarin e
da quel momento diciamo lui poter
rendere possibile la ricerca biomedica e
anche una ricerca un pochettino diversa
questo film cui vi ho mostrato che in
italiano è un sogno per il domani è data
un bellissimo slang americano che pate
for words praticamente vuol dire che
colui che il ricercatore biomedico fa un
investimento molto importante in veste
se stesso anche o tutta la sua vita ma
quando lo fa deve essere consapevole di
una cosa che quell'investimento tornerà
in minima parte verso di lui e dei for
world che andrà per il bene di tutti gli
altri
grazie a tutti voi